what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and we have some very
very extremely exciting Spider-Man news
today but not about Peter Parker about a
different Spider-Man character silk a
live-action silk project has been green
lit we are going to be getting a whole
series but it looks like Sony is also
changing things up for their
spider-verse in a very very big way and
it looks like this could actually be an
extremely good thing for Sony if like I
always mention they pull it off right
but let's just Dive Right into this
article because it's super exciting and
I know everybody wants to hear it it's
from variety.com breaking this news the
title reads Amazon orders multiple
Marvel Sony shows beginning with silk
spider Society from Walking Dead alumni
Angela King so right away awesome news
we get a silk live action series titled
spider society and it's coming from the
Walking Dead's Angela King who did a
phenomenal job with The Walking Dead so
this is great but diving into the
article it says Amazon is officially
moving forward with multiple live action
shows based on the Marvel characters
controlled by Sony the first series
under the deal will be silk spider
society which was developed by The
Walking Dead showrunner Angela King
along with Spider-Man into the
spider-verse producers Phil Lord and
Christopher Miller Kang will serve as
the showrunner and executive producer on
silk as part of a new multi-year overall
television deal she has signed with
Amazon and this next part is actually
very important even though it may not
seem like it it says King Lord and
Miller all executive produce along with
former Sony boss Amy Pascal Sony
Pictures Television is the studio with
Lord and Miller currently under an
overall deal there so Sony Pictures
Television is the studio and Amy Pascal
is still an executive producer and this
is really good and this is why Amy
Pascal consults with Kevin feige the
president of Marvel Studios this is good
because we've seen Sony try to work
without really Consulting Kevin feige
sometimes it works but most of the time
it doesn't however recently we have
learned that Sony has been Consulting
with Kevin feige for all of their
Spider-Man related projects and it has
been said that they are building up a
grand Universe now all of which is going
to be connected and hopefully come
together in a huge movie like spider-ged
it this is really good news pointing to
this actually happening the fact that
they are now producing television series
that are live action in the same
spiderverse proves that they are indeed
building their world they are building a
huge universe and it's all hopefully
going to be connected but let's continue
reading this article it says silk spider
Society will debut domestically on MGM
Plus's linear Channel followed by a
global launch on Prime video which
obviously makes sense because Amazon the
show is based on characters created by
Dan slot and Umberto Ramos for Marvel
Comics it follows Cindy Moon described
as a korean-american woman bitten by the
same spider that bit Peter Parker as she
escapes imprisonment and searches for
her missing family on her way to
becoming the superhero known as silk
okay so this is where things get really
really exciting first off silk is one of
my favorite Spider-Man iterations and I
love love her story if you don't know
her origin like they just briefly
mentioned her origin starts with the
origin of Peter Parker actually getting
bitten by the radioactive spider Silk's
first appearance was in The Amazing
Spider-Man number one when the dying
radioactive spider bites Peter Parker on
the hand it falls to the ground but
before it actually dies it bites Cindy
on the ankle so it is the same spider
that bites Cindy that bit Peter Parker
giving them the same Powers however
their Fates are very very different and
and this is where Sony's overall spider
verse plan comes into play in a really
really cool way you see Ezekiel Sims
comes and he takes Cindy away you see
here's a really really important
Spider-Man fact that you need to know
when Ezekiel Sims first meets Peter
Parker Spider-Man he explains to him
that Spider-Man's Powers were not an
accident the spider that bit him did so
voluntarily and he did this so the
spider could pass its powers on to Peter
Parker before it died and of course also
Cindy Moon as well but in doing so this
made Peter Parker and Cindy a Spider-Man
totem which is a bridge between man and
Beast with the properties of both this
is where Ezekiel then warns Spider-Man
that as a spider totem he was in danger
from those who would seek to destroy
these beings and one of those people was
a person called Morlan now Ezekiel Sims
eventually finds Cindy and he discovers
that she is a spider totem as well and
he warns her that Morland is tracking
her and he is coming for her so she
agree agrees to be hidden inside of a
bunker so that he could never reach her
now before he put her in the bunker he
did train her how to use her powers
Ezekiel Sims having Spider-Man Powers
himself but when he learned that
Moreland was tracking her he put her in
the bunker now she had access kind of to
the outside world via videotapes and she
knew the code to get out of the bunker
however never chose to do so now 13
years later when Peter Parker was well
into him being Spider-Man he eventually
learned about Cindy and he went to set
her free now at first she fought him
saying that Moreland would come for her
but he told her that he was dead and at
the time he was however Moreland had
died a couple of times managing to come
back Cindy was kind of mad and she
fought Peter Parker but eventually the
two of them would go into a very
intimate relationship with each other
now she obviously has many many years of
stories but that's pretty much the gist
of what we need to know based off of
what the article that variety published
told us about what the series was
actually going to be about so the series
coming to Amazon is going to be about
her Origins but here's what is extremely
interesting in the Madame Web movie that
is coming up from Sony as a part of Sony
spider-verse it's going to be a
spider-verse Multiverse movie Madame web
is essentially a cosmic entity in Marvel
Comics she is able to travel through
different universes through the
Multiverse so this is setting up a huge
Multiverse inside of Sony's spider-verse
and this is going to be a part of it
because Ezekiel Sims is reportedly the
villain of Madame web now that is
obviously different from his character
in the comics but it does look like the
whole story of spider totems is going to
be a factor in Sony spider verse it is
also a very very big factor with silk
and obviously as I just mentioned in her
origin story Ezekiel Sims is a big
factor in silk story as well so as far
as Ezekiel Sims being bad or good we
don't really know that because we only
have rumors right now we do have some
leaked set photos that do show us a
character that is believed to be Ezekiel
Sims these these are leaked from The
Madam web set and he clearly does seem
to have some type of Spider-Man
capability so he is definitely a spider
totem thus confirming the spider totem
storyline is going to be a prominent
factor in the spider-verse over at Sony
and now that they are going to be doing
a whole series on Cindy Moon silk this
pretty much confirms the connectivity of
all of it confirming that Sony really
does have some huge plans for their
spider universe and I really think that
this is a home run I think the series
have executed properly is going to be a
fantastic series and I think the whole
idea of having movies and shows much
like Marvel Studios is doing now with
Disney plus is a really great idea and
it's a great way to have even more
awesome Spider-Man characters introduced
in their universe and have them all come
together in a huge movie overall it
seems like Sony has kind of taken a play
from Marvel studios's book and trying to
somewhat replicate it with their own
twist which I think is a great
opportunity let's hope they pull it off
and let's hope that the silk series is
going to be a great series because again
she is a great character but let me know
what you think about all of this
information in the comments down below
let me know how excited you are for a
silk series don't forget to like the
video and subscribe to stay up to date
on all the latest news for live updates
you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf wolf